there's families of victims here today
have you apologized to the victims I
would you like to do so now well should
Zuckerberg maybe take I don't know he's
got 141 bill it's probably not all
liquid could he take 500 mil and figure
out ways to compensate some of the young
women who have been hurt by some of this
stuff and by the way it's not just girls
although they were mostly focusing on
that probably could uh but as you guys
know most of these Congressional
hearings they just kind of bring them in
they smack them around and then nothing
really happens uh in in the real world
although this was an interesting moment
Holly was just going on and just not
letting Zuckerberg off the hook and they
had some of the families of kids who
have been exposed to born I think who
have committed suicide and and just a
bunch of awful things uh and he
basically forc Zuckerberg to get up and
apologize to them right there so let me
ask you this there's families of victims
here today have you apologized to the
victims I would you like to do so now
well they're here you're on National
Television would you like now to
apologize to the victims who have been
harmed by your product show them the
pictures would you like to apologize for
what you've done to these good
people I'm
sorry go the things that your families
have have suffered and this is why we
invested so much and are going to
continue doing industry efforts to uh to
make sure that no one has to go through
the types of things that your families
had
all right so it's a bit of a struggle
session there you might say that's too
heavy-handed by Holly Zuckerberg did get
up and do it I hope he means it
forthrightly that the tools that they've
created on this platform and his his
intention was to meet girls like that
was why he created the Facebook it was
called the Facebook at the time and then
it just became this thing that everyone
has on their phone although I don't have
Facebook on my phone pretty
impressive